win fail OMG cute sorry and yes yes yeah  yeah  [Music]  so you want to vote for a pretty boy  Canadian named Justin what could  possibly go wrong  cute  Drake gonna rep Canada so much more when  Trudeau legally lets him smoke it up in  the six oMG when you know you're just  not ready but your hair is on point when  Justin Trudeau was too hot and perfect  and I don't trust him cute  so if the Chinese call mr. prime  minister sorry that's right be sorry  so if Chinese call Prime Minister  Trudeau little potato head do we have to  call him mr. potato head no that's Prime  Minister potato head  I finally done it every single picture  covered in cute last one  I bet Trudeau's the type to see mean  tweets and dm's the tweeters to see why  they don't like him yeah sorry I would  have liked of dmu but I just don't have  time running a country you know that  one's the sorry Twitter's got nicer  [Music]